hey everybody welcome to the podcast you
guys are in for a treat today because my
guest
is none other than the organizational
psychologist
ted talker extraordinaire and multiple
new york times bestselling author
adam grant this is a guy who was named
wharton's top-rated professor
seven years in a row seven years
straight he's recognized as one of the
world's most cited
most prolific and most influential
researchers in business
economics and work-life balance he's
been featured everywhere
his ted talks have garnered more than 20
million views
and his books include give and take
originals
option b which he co-authored with
cheryl sandberg and his
new banger certain to be another massive
culture shifting bestseller is titled
think again cannot recommend this book
enough i'm a
super fan of atoms have been for a long
time and could not be more excited to
have such a luminary on the show
but before we dive in we're brought to
you today by the plant power
meal planner everything you need to
finally dial in
your nutrition in 2021 for just a dollar
90 a week it provides you access to
literally
thousands of customizable delicious
nutritious easy to prepare
plant-based recipes that are updated
regularly with built-in
automatic grocery delivery of everything
you need plus
access to our team of amazing nutrition
coaches
on the ready to answer all your
questions seven days a week
to learn more and sign up visit
meals.richrol.com
literally for the price of a cup of
coffee you can watch your life change
again that's meals.richroll.com
okay hit that subscribe button if you
haven't already and without further ado
let's get into it with the great adam
grant
well i'm just absolutely delighted to be
able to
share some space with you today uh i've
been a big fan of your work for
a very long time congrats on the success
of the new book think again i just
checked like an hour ago i think it's
like number six on amazon you're killing
it right now
people are really enjoying it um and
uh i'm really excited to to dive into it
with you
before we do that though can we geek out
on michigan for a minute
we have to we have multiple things to
geek out on okay rich let me just say
thank you
your story obviously has been a huge
inspiration to so many people but
every time i look at what you've
accomplished as an athlete
i just think i don't know how you
function in the world
i would love to have your endurance well
that that sensibility is mutual because
i'm fascinated with how you function in
the world i don't know how you get
so much stuff done and how you excel in
so many areas but
perhaps we can get into it a little bit
i mean we have
you know i'm much older than you but
like yourself i grew up
in michigan we moved to washington dc
when i was like seven or eight
but uh i'm from gross point my dad
was a detroit lawyer my mom was an
educator
i was a swimmer you were a diver uh
everybody in my family bleeds maize and
blue
um and uh and and it's just cool to talk
to somebody who's
somewhat of the same world uh
and uh i think we might even know some
of the
same people from that world like when
you went to harvard was joe bernal still
the swim coach there
no i think it was tim murphy when i when
i got it was okay so a little bit later
um i vividly recall i had i had a kind
of an inflection point
in my life when i went to university of
michigan on a recruiting trip for
the swim team and had uh some
interesting moments with bruce kimball
and met
dick kimball and you know wow i'm sort
of connected to that
community my grandfather was captain of
the university of michigan swim team
like back in like 1929
under matt mann who the pool is named
after
amazing oh i didn't i didn't realize
your roots were this deep
okay yeah yeah yeah my dad went to law
school at michigan my mom went to
university of michigan so
lots of overlap all right yeah there's a
ton of overlap here so
we share moms and teacher dad's a lawyer
detroit suburbs i found out
after i became a diver that my
grandmother had been a diver
she never had mentioned it to me and it
just just
came out one day uh my mom went to
michigan
my uncle is the world's most rabid
michigan fan and went to law school
there and i think he hasn't missed an
in-person game in 50 years
wow and i think i think not going to
michigan for college
probably broke my mom's heart yeah
like what are you doing it's like like
leaving a religion i know yeah i know
especially there's something unique
about michigan in that regard too
uh it definitely was similar uh in in my
case as well you felt that too
and then wow so that's also diving lore
i mean the the kimball family
obviously they they i guess they belong
to a place of their own
i remember i actually thought about not
applying to michigan for undergrad
because i was so terrified of the
thought of having dick kimble as a
diving coach
right i i remembered you know friends
who insisted on only doing one and three
meter springboard
being forced to become 10 meter platform
divers and then coughing up blood when
they crashed
i don't want to be that guy yeah i mean
it's it's legendary and i've told this
story before but
uh the experience that i had on this
recruiting trip i was at a party
a house party after a swimming and
diving meat
and bruce kimball handed me a beer
and then he proceeded to perform the
greatest party trick that i'd ever seen
where he did
a standing back flip holding a cup of
beer without spilling any of it
and i just thought that was the most
amazing thing i ever
i ever had seen then i went on my own
journey with alcohol and alcoholism and
recovery
and of course the story of bruce is is
pretty well told in the kind of you know
tragic circumstances that that befell
him
so sad yeah did you dive at harvard
i did and you swam at stanford right i
did yeah yeah yeah
did you dive all four years or just a
year or two
i stopped after my first year how'd you
guess yeah uh
i i don't know you got too busy with
other things that seem to compel your
attention
that's exactly what happened yeah well
the new book is
is amazing i can't think of a better
book
more suited for this particular moment
than the subjects that you're talking
about right now
and in thinking about the book and kind
of
culture at large you know i've spent a
lot of time
just thinking about how we uh
we communicate right now and um
you know my sense is that
we are so increasingly calcified in
our belief systems and the identities
that we form around them
and this is further intensified by
social media algorithms that serve up
what we want to hear
that you know enhances our confirmation
bias
um the kind of tribes that we form
online
and in our analog lives that were kind
of
cueing our membership in good standing
too
and there's in my sense there seems to
be
a velocity behind that like it's
becoming more and more
intense and it's environmental right
the idea being that this is just kind of
happening to us without
any willful input on our part and
the antidote which is the thesis of your
book requires a great deal of
thought and presence of mind and
intentionality and
i see it almost like a war between these
two worlds
and it's difficult to be sanguine
about the future given the amount of
intentionality
that's required to kind of rebut uh
you know the forces that be out there
that are marshaling us in the opposite
direction
i think that's true i i think it's part
of the reason that i wanted to right
think
again is to try to unpack is there
anything we can do
to get more open-minded and to encourage
other people to be that way too
i think i came out more hopeful than i
started i think for a while this book
was that project that i hope someone
else would pursue
someone else go figure this out yeah get
people to you know to choose mental
flexibility over foolish consistency
uh get people to be humble and curious
as opposed to arrogant and
i just nobody wrote the book and
eventually i said all right i need to
take this on
obviously you know you've been working
on this book for a while
and it it is current in the sense that
it
it you know tackles uh covid
in some regard but obviously predates
the capital
insurrection and you know aspects of q
anon and some of the other
you know kind of things that we're
seeing unfold right now when you were
watching
the capital insurrection how are you
thinking about
the ideas presented in the book and how
these these things kind of
you know coalesce it it was a shock was
was the first thing i never thought that
an insurrection would happen in america
it's something you read about happening
in other countries and
thank your lucky stars that we don't
live in one of those countries
and you know the i as an organizational
psychologist i've spent most of my
careers trying to study things that are
timeless
and i've really deliberately resisted
the timely because i'm interested in
ideas
not news i'm interested in you know in
rigorous evidence not current events
and yet this idea of thinking again
uh it i finished the book right around a
time when we're dealing with the
greatest polarization i've ever seen and
you know then an attack on our very
democracy
and my first thought was you know
what everyone's now calling the big lie
that you know the election was stolen
from donald trump
if we could have gotten many people to
rethink their belief in that lie
it's possible the the insurrection
wouldn't have happened at all
and my next thought was okay most of
these people
don't seem to think that they're
undermining democracy
they think they're saving democracy and
that requires a whole re-examination of
you know not just a belief but a belief
system a world view
and i don't i don't know that that i
know how to tackle that
i think i have you know i have some
ideas and insights about how to begin to
chip away at some of those wrong beliefs
but
i think it's an extreme i guess my
reaction was
there's a sequel to this book that needs
to be written about conspiracy theories
about false news that is very different
from
i was trying to deal with what i thought
was you know everyday resistance to
admitting that you're wrong
and to knowing what you don't know and i
think what your question makes me wonder
is
is is the everyday version of that now
extreme enough
that we need that book for more people
than i realized yeah i
i i would like to read that book i think
there is something qualitatively
different now about the way that we
uh you know are magnetized by certain
ideas and the conspiracy theory
is its own kind of genus in all of this
i mean you did talk about it in the book
you have the example of the flat earther
and you have that graphic that circular
graphic
but when you think about conspiracy
theories
in general you're dealing with
a set of people who are under the belief
that they're the ones who are thinking
more open-minded
about this idea they're the ones who
have taken the red pill
they're they're seeing things that are
seeing things more clearly
they're standing outside of the
conventional wisdom
and that makes it very different than
some other kind of well-held belief that
that you know informs identity it does
and it is i think i i think this is
it's a huge uphill battle i've been
reading a lot lately about the
psychology of conspiracy theories why
people adopt them and especially
why or when they might be willing to
reconsider them
and i think it's hard to it's hard to
have this conversation without talking
about cognitive dissonance
right dating back to the classic leon
festenger work
which basically said if you've already
committed to a belief
then any threat to that belief if they
if they force you to treat the world as
a less
pleasant place for you to you know to
challenge your ego
to put aside you know pre-existing
commitments you've made to
walk back statements you've made in
public that it's easier
just to assimilate whatever's going on
into the statements you've already made
and defend your you know your
long-standing beliefs because then you
you avoid the discomfort of doubt and
you get the comfort of conviction
right and i think that that part is
clear
right we we understand why that happens
i think the the undoing
the rethinking the unlearning of those
beliefs is a heck of a lot harder
and i think the the most interesting
thing that i've learned lately
is that there's there's some research on
what's called the cynical genius
illusion
where when somebody's cynical people
tend to assume that means they're smart
because they don't accept things at face
value
it's actually the opposite people who
are extremely cynical tend to be lower
in intelligence than their peers
and of course there's a big difference
between cynicism and skepticism right
cynicism is is not believing anything
you hear
and skepticism is being a critical
thinker and saying
show me the evidence right and one of
the reasons that
cynicism seems to emerge is it's a
defense mechanism
against being manipulated and it's a
defense mechanism that people gravitate
toward
if they get manipulated a lot because
they're not that smart
hmm and i think the ways that we
try to attack that are just it's like
dumping
fuel on a fire because the first thing
that
you know that quote unquote the elite
does or that the mainstream media does
or that
universities do is we go and accuse
people of believing
stupid things and their fear is that
they're not smart
and that's why they're clinging to these
conspiracies in the first place because
they make
they make them feel smart and so i think
we need to be really careful
about you know about threatening
people's intelligence about questioning
people's
you know about questioning people's
ability to
to form judgments and reason and i think
there are better ways to surface that
which we could talk about but
that that was an aha moment for me yeah
it seems like
although intelligence iq and eq
are important we also have to consider
uh you know other aspects of of of
people's lives like the extent to which
they're disenfranchised they're
alienated they're frustrated in their
path
and how those things you know uh
motivate people
to cotton on to ideas that otherwise
they would
you know think better of yeah i i think
that's right and
you know one of the things i've learned
and you know this from the book but i
haven't
i certainly didn't think much about how
to apply it to to these kinds of
conspiracy theories when i was writing
the book
it turns out that how questions tend to
be more powerful than why questions
you go to somebody who believes
something that that you think is
is not consistent with the truth and you
ask them why they believe what they
believe
and they have a bunch of pre-made
reasons that they find compelling
if instead you ask them well how did
that come to be
or how does that work they're much more
likely to see the gaps in their own
understanding and to recognize the
complexity of the issue
and i actually had a chance to to apply
this recently i was talking with a
friend
who believes in some vaccine
conspiracies
that you know the government and big
pharma are in cahoots to
basically pull the wool over your eyes
and convince you that vaccines
are much safer than they really are i
said look i
i i first of all some conspiracies are
real
let's let's put that on the table and we
can make a list of them
secondly i know that there are plenty of
vaccines that have documented
side effects and risks and we can look
even at the published evidence right in
peer-reviewed journals and say look this
is this is a complex issue
what i want to understand though is that
if this is so much worse than you think
it is
why is there not a single scientist with
tenure
who's willing to go against the the
establishment right in a world where the
incentive is to
be right not to just toe the party line
and and also why can you not find a
single credible journalist
who wants to win a pulitzer prize for
exposing this conspiracy
and he couldn't really answer those
questions and then i i
went a step further and i said okay and
just help me think through how a giant
government bureaucracy
and all these pharma companies wouldn't
have a single internal whistleblower
and how they you think they're
incompetent right you told me they're
incompetent
how how would they have even
orchestrated this
to you know to keep the facts from
everybody
who's you know who's in that world and
as he thought through how to do this he
said well you know maybe
maybe maybe they couldn't have maybe
you know people just haven't wanted to
publish the studies that you know they
cast doubt
on vaccine efficacy or safety and maybe
those are
underrepresented in the peer-reviewed
journals and that was a much more
reasonable place than he started
right so the idea and this was the
subject of this new york times
opinion piece basically that that came
out the other day
um the idea being that you approach
these conversations rather
than from the paradigm that you outline
in the book which is
as prosecutor as preacher or as
politician
but rather lead with curiosity ask a lot
of questions
and receive the answers to those
questions without judgment
but rather more curiosity
that's the goal is that accurate yeah i
think that's a great summary of
of both the mindset of approaching this
like a scientist
right and saying look i'm not going to
preach that i'm right i'm not going to
prosecute you for being wrong
but i'm also not going to be a
politician and just tell you what you
want to hear
to try to campaign for your approval
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to as a scientist i'm going to
say you know
rich this is totally fascinating to me
that your beliefs are so different from
mine
and i genuinely want to understand them
better and
if you could help me make sense of how
this works and how this played out
and then you know i also want to
understand yeah i'm sure
i have some beliefs that are wrong i
suspect you also do too right nobody
nobody's omniscient
i'd love to understand what kind of
information
would lead you to consider changing your
mind and i'm also
thrilled to talk about what might change
my mind and then the hope is we're both
gonna find out that
our knowledge was incomplete through
this conversation and of course it
doesn't work if that's a tactic right
because the other person will see right
through it
but if if you adopt what counseling
psychologists call motivational
interviewing
and you really try to understand the
person's reasons for change
and what would lead them to consider
shifting their opinion a little bit
then you might surface information that
would lead them to change their own mind
right so let's dig into that a little
bit deeper but maybe we can start with
elaborating a little bit more
on this prosecutor preacher politician
uh rubric that you've set up here the
original idea comes from a colleague of
mine phil tutlock
who's studied political psychology and
social psychology most of his career
and phil observed that in decision
making in judgment
we spend a lot of time thinking like
preachers prosecutors and politicians
and we're usually not aware of it when
we're doing it a preacher mindset
is essentially believing that you've
already seen the light and now you have
to go and proselytize
to everybody else and get them on board
so you're
you've drunk the intellectual kool-aid
and now your job is to serve it
a prosecuting mindset is more about
proving everyone else wrong
and winning your side of the case and
then
a politician mindset is is really about
saying
okay i've got some constituents here and
i need to lobby for their buy-in
i want their support and my big worry
rich was when i learned about this
framework i thought okay
preaching and prosecuting stop those
stop you from thinking again
because if i know i'm right and i'm sure
you're wrong i don't need to budge
in any of my opinions or any of the
knowledge that i
i hold i just need to convince you to do
that
and in politician mode we see people
sounding a lot more flexible
but it's really just adjusting what they
say
to fit in it's not actually changing
what they believe internally and that
that's just basically flip-flopping
yeah i think i i fall mostly into the
the politicking camp as a really as a
i'm surprised to hear you say that
really why would you say that well i
would have guessed just because
of the way that you've inspired so many
people i would have guessed that that
preaching might be
the default of those three for you i
preaching is very uncomfortable for me
i i'm much more interested in in
approval and being liked
to a default in in in a not so great way
like i've
really made major life decisions based
on approval
or doing this socially except i mean i
was a lawyer for over a decade
you know trying to jam a square peg into
a round hole for
for way too long and very reluctant to
get out of it
uh out of you know fear of social
repercussions and
familial expectations and the like and
you know i i i would sit in
depositions or in hearings
and just see the gray and everything and
just felt like i'm a really bad
advocate because i i really want to
appreciate the nuance in all of this and
can't we just all get along like i'm
conflict-averse i'm a people-pleaser and
you know i host these podcasts and i
want to be challenging in the
conversations but also
i only have the people on that i respect
and admire so
i'm sitting here you know and if i'm
being honest it's like i want adam to
like me i want him to respect me
you know that's that's like you know
just calling myself out
in a vulnerable way over like my own
motivations
and so i i spent a lot of time thinking
about that but i also i want to throw
like a little bit of a test case
out out to you um so i've been
vegan for about 14 years now
and i guess for better or worse part
that's part of my
identity and i've spent a lot of time
thinking about how i um
how i you know embody that ethos how i
carry that message
how i advocate you know for something
that i believe in
and you know i've realized that for my
own personal
you know makeup i don't feel
uh it doesn't feel natural to me to be a
preacher about it
i'm not interested in taking other
people's inventory and criticizing
their decisions i don't think it's
effective uh
and i kind of settled into
a mode that's a little bit outside of
your paradigm which is this idea of
of being kind of a lighthouse like if i
live my life well
and equip myself as an athlete as uh
you know somebody who is excelling
intellectually mentally
emotionally and just living well it acts
more like a magnet or
a tractor beam that will bring the
receptive
audience to me who might be willing or
interested to hear
about it and it also goes back to
12 step and how i got sober and the
tools that i learned
in the program which are all about not
giving advice but just sharing your
experience and so i'm curious about how
that fits into how you think about these
ideas of
of influencing people and getting people
to kind of open up their minds and
consider different
concepts wow i think that's brilliant
i i'm kicking myself now because if we
had had this conversation a year ago
i would have written that in to think
again oh well now i'm bummed
i i wish i'd met you earlier it's i it's
not my
it's not my idea though but it's just
something that seems to
work better than any of these other
three options although it doesn't start
with a p
yeah you can come up with a yeah it's
it's not alliterative
and i no i think i think you articulated
it
so beautifully though it's
there's there's a lot to react to there
so i want to i want to double click on a
few things you said let's just start
with the lighthouse idea
i think that that might be the most
compelling work around
that i've i don't even want to call it a
workaround that's i think that's not
doing
justice to it it's the most compelling
solution i can think of
to the tension between what i guess was
my preferred alternative to preaching
prosecuting and politicking which is
thinking like a scientist
and the need if you want to influence
people in the world
to do some preaching and i've i've
always been uncomfortable with that
tension
because so i guess i should take a step
back and just say thinking like a
scientist
is is what i would love for more people
to do more often
and i don't mean you have to go and wear
a white coat all the time or
carry around test tubes or even own a
microscope right
what i mean is that the just the
broadest idea
of of science is the pursuit of
knowledge and truth
and if your identity is anchored in
being a scientist it means that
you don't have to stick to a certain set
of beliefs at any one time
you want to find out what's going to be
effective or
what the right way is to live your
values and that means
when you form an opinion it's a
hypothesis you can go out and test it
you can
observe you can interact you can run
experiments and the hope is that you're
as excited to find out that you were
wrong
as you are to prove that you were right
because either way
you've you know you've you've
potentially learned something and i
would argue even you learn more when you
discover that
your hypothesis was false then when then
when you validate it
and and yet phil tutlock when
when i talked to him first about this
framework saying okay
i i want everyone to think more like
scientists he said well
yeah but sometimes you have to talk much
more like a preacher in order to be
heard
yeah you know just look at any pundit on
tv
or any leader who gives an inspiring
speech
and i've never liked that as as
something that you have to do
and i think you you just gave an
alternative which is to say okay i can
think like a scientist
i can test in my own life whether i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna be at my best in you know in
an ironman
when when i go vegan right that's an
experiment you ran
and then once i do that if i'm willing
to share what i've learned from that
and i talk about that publicly i don't
have to tell other people to do it i
don't have to preach
about it i'm just i'm just telling my
story and that will draw people to me
i think that i just think that's
ingenious
well it's effective it seems to be more
effective
and i think it's all you know a sort of
corollary to that for me
is is a more kind of buddhist or
eastern philosophical perspective on
this which is that i'm not attached
to whether or not i'm convincing anybody
to change
like i'm just i'm carrying this certain
vibration
i'm happy to talk about issues that i
care about if you
approach me or you're interested but i'm
not interested in proselytizing
i'm interested in in you know living my
best life
and it's this idea of attraction rather
than promotion which is
core to the whole 12-step philosophy
yes and it's it's so consistent with his
stance of motivational interviewing
which is i'm not here to force you to
change i'm here to
help you if i can uncover your own
motivation for change but that's up to
you
and i think the person on the receiving
end of it
feels the difference between somebody
who is
really wed to an outcome versus somebody
who's like hey i'm just telling you this
like
it's your business what you do with this
information or not
it's such a paradox because
my biggest advice is going into
prosecutor mode it just
i think the cartoon that could be my
life story
is the one where this guy is sitting at
a computer
and his wife says what's wrong and he
says
someone is wrong on the internet you're
right yeah yeah and he can't sleep
that's me it's just as some as
as a social scientist when somebody
believes something that
goes against the weight of the evidence
i
think i felt for a long time like it was
my moral responsibility to try to
correct them
right and not only was that
way too high and mighty of me and
self-righteous it also didn't work
to your point about effectiveness have
you i don't i don't see you
trolling people on twitter though like
you don't get involved in that kind of
stuff
no i but i have i've written some
articles
that i think led people to really
misjudge me
as you know as being actually a close
colleague of mine uh
one of the people who i consider part of
my challenge network not not my support
network
uh one of my most thoughtful critics
said to me do you want to spend your
career being a professional debunker
right i said no i want to i want to
build ideas up not tear them down but i
also believe that if somebody is selling
snake oil that you know we we should
make the world aware of that and that
that tension has been really tricky for
me
but i think this idea of being a
lighthouse
and saying look here's my analysis of
the evidence and here's my experience
applying it
what do you make of that the irony in it
for me is
i it really invalidates one of my core
beliefs which is when you have a goal
you should work as hard as you can to
achieve it and in this case it is very
buddhist like you said
letting go of the goal a little bit and
saying look i my
my mission here is not to persuade it's
to share it's to teach
it's to learn that actually makes me
more persuasive
precisely because i'm not trying to be
persuasive yeah well i think
it gets into the mysteries of of the
of the human mind in the sense that what
wins the day
isn't necessarily the most sound proof
logical argument uh more often than not
at least in my own experience and i'm
curious what you make of this
it's if you can if you can really
emotionally connect with the person that
you're talking to
and engender some level of trust which
has nothing to do with logic
that ultimately can be the lever that
moves the needle
more than you know the you know the
facts of the case or the scientific
aspects of whatever it is that you're
discussing
i mean that's certainly consistent with
my read of the data it's stunning to me
that when i think about these
experiments that corinne benderski has
run for example
that just saying to somebody who has a
different opinion than you
i respect people who have clear
principles
is enough to reduce animosity and
lead to more openness in a conversation
it's one of the simplest demonstrations
of your point
and yet it makes me think that maybe
what
what you sort of sheepishly said is you
know
more of a politician sometimes than i
would like to be is an advantage
because it leads you to build that
connection and that trust
and i have to tell you just to loop back
a little bit rich i'm i'm flattered
that you want me to like you because
here here
i come on your show thinking i i always
wanted to be an athlete i was never
talented enough at any sport to become a
real athlete i got just good enough to
dive in college
and i look at what you've achieved and
think i wish i had the endurance
that i could do 300 plus miles
of running swimming and biking i wish i
could
i could have the discipline in my eating
habits and make nutrition enough of a
priority in my life
uh to become as fit as you've become and
so i came on here thinking okay
my this this is completely a trojan
horse for me
uh i didn't i didn't necessarily write
the book in order to have this
conversation but
part of the joy of writing a book like
this is cool i'm gonna come here i'm
gonna soak up a little bit of the way
that rich roll thinks
and maybe i will end up adopting a
better philosophy of fitness for my own
life
so that that's my secret mission for
coming all right well we can we can talk
all of that you know at some later point
i'm very flattered that you would say
that and i would have to say
you know likewise like when you dm'd me
on twitter i was like i couldn't believe
that you dm'd me i was so excited so
it's a mutual admiration uh society here
i'll try not to make it i think that you
gotta stop throwing diving under the bus
come on diving deserves to be thrown
under the bus no it doesn't come on
it does let me well okay so i let me let
me prosecute myself on this one okay
right
because uh yeah i want to hear your your
counter argument and
i know this is this is more going into
debate mode than i've advocated
for in the book but you know what maybe
we should rethink some of the things i
wrote
in the spirit of the book uh i think the
thing about diving
is it's
it looks really complex but it's just a
very small number of skills
like you you learn you learn timing on
the board
so that you can jump a little bit higher
you learn to throw your arms forward or
back to create rotation
you work on your flexibility so that you
can spin faster
you learn to twist a little bit and then
you just have to get air sense or good
visuals
and put your hands in front of your head
and a good dive takes less than two
seconds to execute
compare that with the slog of you go
into a pool
i so i learned i learned to
do a front two and a half with a full
twist so
i could flip twice twist once dive in
headfirst
and that took me three years of serious
diving practice to do
in six years of a life in the pool i
could not learn to swim the butterfly
stroke
literally cannot do the butterfly which
you competed in
and you can swim faster in a butterfly
than i can swim freestyle
yeah how is what i learned not easier
than what you meant
because to each his own like i could
never i i couldn't dive to save my life
no matter how much i practice so anybody
who's very i did yeah and anybody who's
very proficient in a specific thing
tends to under index for how difficult
that thing is so i
basically all i'm saying to you is
celebrate the fact that you're
a diver and stop saying that it's like
the nerd sport and all of that
and that maybe the divers will be happy
happier that you do that
but i'm interested in because you have
this this background as a
as a diver and as an athlete is there a
nexus between
what you learned in sport and this
you know incredible superhuman focus
that you have
and this you know ability to be
productive at a level that most people
can't comprehend
well i i don't accept any of the
premises okay of the question
but i realize i realize there's a
perception in the world that i get a lot
done
and it's incredibly strange to me
because
most days i feel totally unproductive
and i don't know if i just have
unreasonable goals for myself or
or how to explain that but i think
one of the things that one of the things
that diving
i don't know if i learned it in diving
or if it just
reinforced the value of it for me and
then it became
more hardwired was just
the the value of focusing on one thing
at a time
the number of people i know who are
multitaskers not necessarily even in the
minute but in the day
is much greater than i would like it to
be i think that computers are great at
parallel processing
as humans we are built to be serial
processors
and i don't just mean that if i'm
checking my phone while we're talking
then i'm not gonna
be coherent i mean that if i'm trying to
accomplish two things today
i'm gonna do both of those less
effectively than if i just have one goal
today
and that was what diving really was it
was yeah i would go to practice
and i would i would max out you know
usually it was two and a half or three
hours before
i start to get blisters on my feet or
you know from repeated days of practice
or you know my shoulders would start to
hurt or you know my form would just
start to fall apart and i needed to take
a break
but then it meant i'm studying the video
of my own practice
to really internalize what my coach is
telling me i'm analyzing
what changes i might want to make that
my coaches didn't see
i'm heading over to a trampoline to
practice some of the techniques that
don't require water
i'm working on my stretching and that
single mindedness
was i think other than having incredible
coaches
was the only reason that i got good at
diving and
it's it's just it's kind of
it's startling to me it's startling is
the wrong word it's it's mesmerizing to
me
that people think you can be good at
anything when
you're trying to be good at multiple
things and i'm not saying you can't you
can't master multiple things in a year
or even in a month but what i want to do
is
i want to have not work life balance or
even
project project balance i want to have
rhythm
which means you know today i've got one
song that i'm playing or better yet i've
got one verse of that song
and then tomorrow we'll go over to the
course right i mean that that dovetails
pretty nicely into this idea that you
have about
attention management versus time
management and
your ability to be productive is
calibrated with your ability to
uh really invest your your attention and
your focus on
one thing at a time yeah i think
my big frustration with time management
is that the more you try to optimize
your calendar
the more aware you become of how many
hours you waste in the day in the week
and that that just is it's discouraging
and deflating to me
and i decided at some point that what i
wanted to do was get better at managing
my attention
and that meant that i had to have
clarity about the people in the projects
that mattered to me
and then if i was laser focused on those
it wouldn't matter how long anything
took
because my time is aligned with my
values and my goals
and i think that you know in in some
cases that just means
well no i guess i guess what i would say
is
attention management sometimes gets me
in trouble because my attentional
filters are so high
that my peripheral vision gets gone and
if i'm
if i'm locked into a goal of finishing a
task today let's say i'm i'm writing
an op-ed uh like that new york times one
that you referenced
i set a goal a few weeks ago of
finishing a draft of it
and i was late to two meetings i
missed one deadline right and i think i
i'm lucky to be in a job where i have
the freedom to you know to set my own
deliverables
and i've also let everyone i know who
works with me know that one of my
biggest vices is
that i have a chronic inability to
disengage from a task
until it's done to my satisfaction or at
least until i've made real progress on
it
because i think those moments of flow of
deep work are
there i don't wanna say they're rare but
they're precious they need to be
protected and
i wanna i wanna get every ounce of
creativity and energy out of them when i
when i get into them yeah i mean you
can't task switch when you're in that
process of creation and there is a
a real qualitative difference between
makers and managers like makers really
need to protect
that time to do the thing that they do
and you can't you can't toggle in
between tasks when you're in the process
of
of trying to make something and so it's
not surprising that
it would compel you to be late or miss
other things because
the priority has to go towards taking
advantage of that
flow when it when it descends upon you
whereas
the manager mindset is very different
they're they're tasks switching all the
time and it's about their interactions
with lots of people
and lots of emails and meetings and all
of that kind of stuff which
are really you know just massive
distractions
to anybody who is more of a maker or
a creator yes and i think this is one of
the opportunities in front of us now
with remote work
becoming very real for millions if not
hundreds of millions or billions of
people
i think i keep thinking of this leslie
perlow experiment
where she said what if we just give
people
quiet time three mornings a week where
they're
told don't schedule meetings no
interruptions you can actually just
concentrate on focused work
and she did this at a fortune 500
company in india with engineers
if people were encouraged to do that
themselves 47
above average productivity wow if the
organization instituted it as a policy
and said look we mean this tuesday
thursday friday
no meetings no interruptions before noon
above average productivity and if you
break that down
what's going on there well some of it is
you are just benefiting from more flow
and more deep work
but some of it is also just plain
efficiency that you check your inbox
after lunch
having had a productive morning and you
realize that six people had the same
question
and now instead of having six different
conversations you can call
those people together in one meeting it
only takes one hour out of your day
and then you've also helped those people
build a network of acquaintances or
maybe even strangers who didn't
realize that they were working on
similar problems and
i've watched a lot of organizations just
say you know what we can't protect
people's time
because we have customers or we have
clients that
you know that that impose demands on us
and my response to them has been
well actually don't you think this is
how you teach your clients to be more
effective and productive too
to say look we are here to be available
to you and helpful to you wherever we
can
and in order to do the best job not only
reacting to your problems and fighting
every fire that comes up
but also really rethinking how we solve
problems in the first place or better
yet how to prevent problems at scale
we need some protected time and so of
course we're happy to hear from you if
it's an emergency
but we're going to have one day a week
where we don't schedule meetings
or we're going to have a couple mornings
a week where we don't take calls and
we want you to know that's part of how
we serve you it's interesting i mean the
the it's counterintuitive in the sense
that from a managerial perspective you
would think that people would then just
use that time to go [ __ ] off and do
whatever they want they're not going to
actually
use that for some kind of deep work
they're gonna go
you know i don't know go run errands or
something like that
well if you're a bad manager that's
probably what they will do right because
you haven't you haven't earned any trust
or loyalty
but if you're a manager who you know who
instead of being a micro manager is a
macro manager who says
my job is to figure out the purpose and
the mission
of the team in the organization and then
help you identify your
your unique individual role and see your
contribution here
and then i'm gonna get out of the way
and not tell you how to do everything or
when to do everything
you get a lot of intrinsic motivation in
response to that and we've got
at this point almost half a century of
evidence on
on the benefits of what i guess
classically douglas mcgregor would have
called a theory
why as opposed to theory x approach
where you know whether you believe that
people are lazy and can't be trusted or
people are intrinsically motivated by
mastery and learning and purpose
those beliefs often become
self-fulfilling prophecies and you get
exactly what you expected
yeah interesting well as somebody who
has spent their
entire career kind of devoted to better
understanding
the psychology of the workplace this
past year
has to be you know fascinating for you
to see the ascent of of the home office
and you know everything that that covid
has has brought us
and the disruptions in how we work so
what are some of the insights that
you've been able to develop
out of this you know very strange and
unique year that we've just
experienced there have been a lot not
surprisingly this is the experiment that
nobody opted into
and since we're stuck with it we might
as well be learning from it
i think one of my my first
i guess one of the first revelations for
me was ethan bernstein and haley blunden
collected data on just march through may
how is communication changing now that
essentially everybody
who could is working remotely and they
found that communication with strong
ties went up about 40
on average that with your closest
colleagues your boss
your direct reports the clients that
you're in touch with regularly
you knew you weren't just going to run
into them or you weren't flying out to
see them
and you worked hard to schedule extra
opportunities to connect with them
usually over zoom communication with
weak ties though
you're more distant acquaintances your
suppliers the mentor you occasionally
talk to
that was actually down 10 and this is
bad news when it comes to
rethinking things getting a fresh
perspective because weak ties tend to
give us more novel information than
strong ties
strong ties tend to know the same people
in the same stuff that you do they
give you a redundant knowledge weak ties
are traveling different circles they're
meeting different people they're
learning different things
so they're much more likely to open up
fresh access to a creative idea
and because we're not having those
spontaneous creative collisions
like we used to before the pandemic i
think one of the things we have to
figure out is how do we engineer
interactions between people and their
more distant acquaintances
or allow them even to learn from
strangers and i think
i don't think we we have good i don't
think we have good practices
yet to figure that out how have you
navigated that rich
well i'm very lucky in the sense that
i've been able to continue to pursue
my living where a lot of people are are
are not so lucky
so i feel extremely grateful um a big
part of
this show that i do which is the the
graviment of my vocation
is sitting across from another
individual live
and doing it in person and you know
we've set up safety protocols and i've
been able to do that to some extent but
you know like what we're doing right now
some of them have been forced to be
uh you know on a digital platform which
is not my preference like for me
this experience is all about like trying
to connect as deeply as possible with
the person that i'm talking to
and and very often these people become
part of my life maybe they become part
of my challenge network
or my support network or my board of
advisors
or just friends and yeah that's
incredibly
valuable to me i mean it's a gift to be
able to share
you know the wisdom of people like
yourself with so many people
but the enriching aspect of it for me
is is the in-person connection and and
my kind of
personal strategy with all of these
conversations
is that the emotional connection comes
first it's less about the information
like i trust that if i can connect with
the person who's sitting across from me
find a way in to really identify with
them
that whatever information needs to be
imparted will be imparted and i just try
to be as present as possible
for that and i i'm able to achieve that
to some extent
when i'm looking at you on a screen but
it's not the same
well it still comes through loud and
clear to me i can i can feel it i can
see it
i can hear it i should say first of all
i would love to be friends
in case in case that's on your right on
your list i'm going to call you my
friend now
so all right i'm in we're friends
consider it done
i i i mean i felt coming in i felt like
i knew you already because i've i've
followed your work with such great
interest and
it's so clear what you stand for and
what your values are uh
that i i felt like i knew you so there
was that that connection even if
swimmers and divers are
are supposed to not get along right but
i feel like it's the weirdest pairing of
two sports
into one that i've that it shouldn't
exist i'm sure
opinions on that well these two things
both involve water let's put them on a
team together
right i guess there's also a masochistic
element of both though which is
i think you both both of us opted into
more more deliberate pain
than many sports require yeah i don't i
don't remember basketball or
soccer ever hurting nearly as much as
diving did uh
yeah swimming is a glutton for people
who who enjoy
self-punishment i can tell you that but
rich i i did want to ask you
sure i've i've been i've been curious
about you know
there's just i think we're gonna have a
wealth of data in the next few years
about in-person versus video versus
audio interactions and one thing i have
noticed i'm
i'm also drawn to the rapport and the
connection and
i i've always been the person who if i
have a choice i want to sit down in a
room with someone because
i can i feel like i can bond with them
more i also it's easier to get into that
that burstiness of you know we're we're
just we have this energy flying back and
forth and
and the conversation is literally
bursting with ideas
i have noticed though in the past few
years of a podcasting
that i think i have deeper conversations
sometimes when i'm not in the room
with people and it's because i'm less
attuned to this question of
okay how do they react to what i just
said uh do they like me you know are
is it was that awkward or did it build
rapport
and i'm much more comfortable with an
awkward pause
i'm much more interested in in trying to
figure out where is this conversation
going to take us and so
i wonder if there's a purity of
discussion that comes from distance
what has that been like for you that's
very interesting
um
[Music]
there's certainly some truth in that the
question that popped into my head when
you were describing that
is whether there's a difference between
when you're doing it on zoom and you're
looking at the person versus
an audio only platform where you don't
have to worry
about like i'm i don't want to look down
at my notes i want to maintain eye
contact with you but if we were doing
this on a different platform
where we weren't doing video and i could
be staring at my notes
maybe i would have better questions
chambered
but i also wouldn't be as fully present
for the experience that's happening
yeah there's a trade-off there yeah so i
don't know
and and to kind of answer the other
aspect of your question
you know how has this experience been i
mean outside of the podcast itself
i went into this pandemic thinking i've
been training for this my whole life
like i'm an introvert i like my solitary
time
this is going to be just fine i'll be
able to cancel all these things on my
calendar that i didn't really want to do
anyway and and focus on some deep work
and just being with my family but
none of us would have expected that it
would be going on this long and even
you know despite those those
predispositions that i have i do feel
lonely and i do miss my friends and
you know i find myself yearning for that
interpersonal connection
and i feel terrible for my kids who are
being deprived of
experiences that you know no child
should be deprived of in terms of their
ability to socially interact with their
peers
yeah uh well first of all i'm sorry to
hear that i think
i can relate to so much of that and i i
think it
everyone assumed going in that
introverts were going to have an easier
time with this than extroverts and
this is another bernstein blunden at all
finding there was no difference
in the well-being of introverts and
extroverts during the early stages of
the pandemic
and i think that's in part because
everyone craves connection
even those of us who are introverts
you're one i'm one we are energized by
interactions with other people
uh we're also more likely to be
overstimulated by too much of that
interaction yeah
and that i think that's where the the
physiological difference between
extroverts and introverts
lies according to the the science there
but
i think the the loneliness piece of this
is real for a lot of people and i wonder
i i think one thing i've i've started to
rethink and i really underestimated
is just how much casual interaction
matters in my life uh i never thought
just you know
seeing somebody at a restaurant right
without even talking to them necessarily
right and it never dawned on me that
that was part of feeling a sense of
of community or you know just
deep belonging in a place and i think
that
my hope is i'll appreciate that now in a
way that i differ that i didn't before
well in thinking about the workplace and
what this year
has taught us you talked a little bit
about
enhancements in productivity um what do
you think
what's your estimation of once we get
back to
you know our ability to safely interact
like what is gonna
snap back to the way it was before and
what's not i mean we're seeing
migrations of people moving out of
cities and finding you know
places to live that are more affordable
etc so
i think certainly there's permanent uh
implications to this
where people are realizing they didn't
need to do a lot of the things they were
doing before
and yet we do have to uh get back to
some level of healthy interpersonal
interaction so what does that
you know where's your thinking in terms
of that i wish i had a crystal ball
i think it's it's definitely still a
mystery i i can tell you
the data that i've seen so far would
would predict a few things
first one is nick bloom and his
colleagues just did a
nationally representative survey of 15
000 americans
and they found that essentially people
are expecting to do
usually somewhere between 20 and 25 of
their work days remote
and that's taking into account
individual preferences as well as the
organizational policies that are
starting to emerge
and most of that is hybrid that's not
you know a bunch of companies saying
we're going to be fully in the office
and a bunch of workplaces saying we're
going to be fully remote
that's most people and most leaders
saying you know we'd love to have people
in the office three four days a week
and then work from anywhere the rest the
challenge with that
is what kind of office space do you need
right if
you know if you want do you want
everyone to be there three days then you
need a huge office and it's a major
waste
are you gonna do shift work like a
hospital
where people come in at different times
or even on different days well then
you're missing the
you know the sense of cohesiveness in a
culture
uh i think those are the kinds of
questions that a lot of leaders are
grappling with right now
i think one thing we can be we could be
reasonably confident in predicting
is we're not going to see we're not
going to see a return to this
giant hub tiny spokes model that used to
organize
most workplaces right where everybody's
uh you know wanting to be at
headquarters
and then you know you see occasional
people who are
you know in satellites i think we're
going to see probably a much smaller hub
and then more affordable places to work
in different parts of a country or
different parts of the world for a lot
of organizations but
giant caveat on this is people want to
be where the most senior leader is
they want to be where they can get face
time with powerful people
they want to be where they can get
mentored by experienced
experts and they want to be where they
think
they can be part of what is the real
community yeah
and i don't know how i don't see that
going away
and so i think we're still going to end
up with hubs they're just going to be
smaller hubs
right right it wasn't that long ago that
the idea of working from home was this
huge benefit
and now the idea of getting to go into
an office just seems
so appealing you know it's it's very
strange how the mind works around that
but i would i would tend to agree with
that i mean i think it's going to be
fascinating to see
and and i'm wondering do you have your
finger on the pulse of
people's satisfaction with their
vocation when they're working from home
like in this new situation like are
people
happier like setting aside the other
aspects of kova
like do they enjoy this more or are they
um you know waiting until they can go
back into the office like where does
that fall
it's another giant question mark because
what we have are data pre-pandemic
when nobody had the same experience
working remotely that we do now
and then we have data during the
pandemic when we have all these
confounds of
you know i'm afraid i might get coveted
and there are limitations on what i can
do and who i can see
my guess is though there is there's
probably a net benefit to flexibility
that doesn't mean you should be
permanently remote right but to have the
choice to work from
from wherever you want and to do that at
least part of your time
i think that that seems to be good for
well-being and
the early date on this there was a
meta-analysis uh cagendren and harrison
they accumulated every study that had
been done to date on what then was
called telecommuting
which sounds like a thing of the 1990s
but they basically meant remote work and
they found that as long as people
came to work two and a half days a week
performance was higher satisfaction was
higher and there were no cost to the
quality of co-worker relationships
and i think that then tracks with a lot
of what we're seeing in the pandemic
which is
people don't like their jobs less on
average when they're working remotely
uh they found that they you know there
are some things they like better and
there are some things they like worse
uh i think the you know the general
upsides have been people love the
autonomy and freedom
they appreciate not having to commute
although some of them will choose to
commute again
uh they like also you know in in some
cases
the fact that they get to choose just a
work environment
where they're comfortable um i think on
the flip side
people miss the structure they miss the
community they miss the culture
and i think we want all of those things
so i think we're gonna mostly need to be
hybrid to get all those things yeah i
mean zoom fatigue is real
what what's behind that for you because
i've been hearing a lot about this and
i've felt it from time to time
when you talk about zoom fatigue what's
contributing to that for you
i'm not somebody who's on tons of zoom
calls so i might not be the best
person to feel this question but i i
just i don't
like the static nature i don't like
sitting still staring at a screen what i
don't know i don't know what it is i
can't put my finger on it but
it makes me feel very restless like i
just want to get up and
move around mm-hmm i don't know i mean
we got it
i mean it's got to be a thing that's
that's you know it's not like it's going
to be in the dsm
5 or whatever but uh but it's it's it's
definitely a real condition
i mean what are some of the experiences
that people have shared with you about
that
what i'm seeing so far yeah for some
people it's it's just i'm too static
which it sounds like it's your
experience for some people it's
the the exhaustion of talking into a
screen
and trying to read people's facial cues
or parse tone in a way that's never
quite as clear as if you're actually in
the same room for some people it's
you know it's a lack of you know of a
sense of just being in the same place
uh and you know that that's just
interfering with connection and
my guess is of all these factors just
the sitting still
staring at a screen that that would
probably be the biggest contributor to
it
uh but we have a lot of people have the
flexibility to try to change that right
i've watched a lot of people say
all right i don't need to be on camera
i'm doing walking meetings
or we've even agreed as a team that
we're gonna take a couple of our
standing meetings and we're gonna make
those
hey you can do a workout it probably
shouldn't be an intense workout you
shouldn't go swimming definitely
right you know you can go for a walk or
you can go for a light jog
uh or even you know play catch outside
with your kids
right during a couple of these meetings
a week and i
i think that we've been too wedded to
the idea that you always have to sit in
front of a computer
in order to be working and i just don't
think that's true anymore and that
that's on my basic
list of things we could probably rethink
a little more than we do
yeah i mean i i'm certainly no fan of
how it's being used
in for for for high school education
right now i've got a daughter
who you know she's on zoom from like
eight to four
doing classes and she's just not wired
to
sit and stare at a screen like that and
then she's got homework and she's in an
art high school and then she's got her
art projects
and the stress level and the anxiety
with
her is through the roof and i'm like
what is this for
is this this is not in service to her
best interest right now
it's really deeply problematic i think
i'm sad to hear that and i'm also a
little surprised
because i've read evidence now both from
a uk study and a u.s study
that teenagers are actually doing better
from a well-being
perspective so lower depression lower
anxiety rates
uh during parts of this pandemic and it
seems to be the case that one of the big
mechanisms
behind that is it's hard to get bullied
over zoom
and you don't quite worry as much about
what you're wearing and
who's excluding you at the lunch table
it's this virtual and
i guess the virtual environment is an
equalizing force in some ways
and i it's almost just like at work
where it's this double-edged sword there
are things that got better there are
things that are harder
and i i wonder if on average that's the
experience for
you know at least older kids in online
school yeah i hadn't heard that before
that's super interesting i mean
all the things that i'd seen were that
depression and anxiety
were way higher like on the rise as a
result of this with
with young people i think so it seems to
be age specific
uh i think younger kids are having a
harder time i think for for teenagers
who are more tech savvy and
have a lot of the existing relationships
where they can stay in touch and let's
face it a lot of them were just texting
already
right so it's not like everybody lost
all their in-person time
uh i think that that piece of it seems
to be different and then also
it's probably still too early to have
any real sense of this but my my read
from some of the initial
data is that uh during lockdown
is when some of these well-being
benefits emerged where everybody was in
the same remote scenario
and you know i think as as we started to
see more disparities with
some kids in school some kids who are
stuck remote
i think that's probably exacerbated
excuse me it's exacerbated the problems
and
maybe minimize some of the benefits too
right right like there was a democratic
uh you know impact on everybody equally
as a result of
the lockdown yeah which is again just
like at work
if if 90 of your team is in the same
place
you don't want to be the one person
calling in virtually right if you can
avoid it
from from you know the caribbean or
something like that
while everyone else is stuck i'm on the
beach great to see you all
right well i want to get back to some of
the ideas in in
and think again um and i i was we were
talking about michigan earlier i mean
when i
uh when when i was young we moved to
washington dc which is really where i
grew up
and my dad was a government lawyer so we
were kind of
in this inside the beltway community
and this is like you know the late 70s
early 80s
and you know in our neighborhood there
were
republicans democrats my next-door
neighbor was a
was a senator like and i just recall
even though there were all kinds of
people on different sides of the aisle
politically
there was a level of comedy
that i think has disappeared like we
could we were friends with all these
people we could
have parties and they would all come
over and everybody got along just fine
and this is really no longer the case
and i
i do find myself despairing over our
ability to commune productively
and communicate effectively and your
book is very much an antidote to that
but whatever you know the gestalt of
social forces have put us into this
place like
how is this you know how does this play
out for you are we going to continue on
this path like i know you're
you know you're you're you're looking at
this mostly from the perspective of
we what we can do as individuals and and
organizations to
rebut this but on a more kind of you
know national scale
like how are you thinking about the the
future of our ability to communicate
healthily
i've been thinking about it a lot and my
first thought is always
as an organizational psychologist i
don't have the expertise to
even begin to analyze this question we
should be talking to political
scientists and sociologists
probably some anthropologists as well
because we're i think we're essentially
in a place now where we've got
two foreign cultures that do not like
what the other side
is supposedly standing for and
so most of what i've been doing is just
a lot of reading and a lot of asking
questions to try to understand the
causes and
and some of the remedies better i don't
know where we go from here
i think that one of the things that
happened you know post
election post insurrection is i just saw
people i really respect
intellectually get
crushed and in some cases people
attempted to cancel them
for calling for respect and
i don't i don't see how we make any
progress without
giving people just the basic dignity
they're owed as human beings
i i like i like this distinction that
christy rogers and her colleagues make
uh which is between ode and earned
respect owed respect being that basic
you are a human and therefore
i think your your ideas and your
emotions matter
and then earn respect being okay
depending on your performance or your
contribution
or your credibility i might listen to
you
more carefully i might take what you say
a little bit more seriously in my own
life
and i think the idea that we should
abandon own respect
that you can solve this problem by
saying well i think
you don't respect me and therefore i'm
not going to respect you
like that's that's first grade
playground behavior
right i think that we need to be clear
about how we earn respect in this
in this society and ideally i mean this
is extreme but i would love to see
people start keeping score a little bit
let's go through you know we we have a
lot of debate about media as
media and social media let's go through
people who make claims and predictions
and let's actually track who turns out
to be right and wrong
and let's hold ourselves accountable
before we have the data
for following and listening to the
people who get things right more often
and rich as you know my reading the
evidence is the people who get things
right more often
are the people who admit they're wrong
more often right yeah
and that needs to become a currency
socially right
saying you're wrong needs to be a sign
that you are willing to think like a
scientist
that you are interested in learning and
updating your beliefs
when better logic or data come along and
i don't know how to get us there but
that's where i want to go
well the keeping score thing though is
part of the problem as well like when
you look at twitter
it's all about it's not about truth or
nuance it's about signaling to your
respective tribe that you're
a member in good standing and the point
scoring is all about
taking people down or holding people to
account for
an idea that doesn't neatly fit into
the you know the the prescribed ideology
of that particular tribe
i don't think it has to be that way
though right there are communities on
twitter that have
adopted different values and different
norms i know academic twitter
is a popular hashtag and there are
entire subfields of people
we saw it with epidemiologists last
spring and continuing to the present
we've seen it with you know with people
who are debating hot issues across
you know very complex fields
i think i mean i've made a concerted
effort to follow people
whose conclusions i disagree with
because i admire the integrity of their
thought process
and that means i see information that
constantly
questions my you know my convictions but
that's not a threat to me
i don't have ego invested in that i'm on
twitter to learn and to teach
right and that means you know if if i'm
accessing different perspectives from
people
who have high standards of rigor i'm
learning and i think your
your point is well taken that social
media and i think the traditional media
has done this for a long time too
uh really rewards preaching and
prosecuting
the person with a sound bite that can
that can kind of elevate their tribe
and take down the other tribe is the one
who gets amplified the most
but i think as consumers of of
information we have choices around that
right i don't have to share i don't have
to validate people
who are just always trumpeting the party
line what i want to amplify are the
people who are making me think and
rethink
and i guess i guess as a
with one of my hats as an educator the
place i would start working on this is
in schools
i think i mean we know you you read in
the book that
i i i really did not expect this that if
kids grow up believing in
in false knowledge like the earth is
flat as an extreme example
if you wait until middle school or high
school to try to debunk that
it's already harder right you actually
need to
you know sort of take on science myths
in elementary school
in order to to both get the the
principles that are aligned with the
truth as we know it
um you know on the table early but also
to teach them that a lot of things that
intuitively feel true to you are false
and you need to
you know constantly be in in the mindset
of asking and learning
and with that in mind i would say maybe
one of the best long-term investments we
can make as a country
is to say let's teach the next
generation of kids
to be eager enthusiastic curious humble
rethinkers
yeah wouldn't that be nice right i mean
i i there's so many
things about education that need to be
overhauled with respect to that i think
and that that could be a whole other
podcast but i think it's super important
and one of the reasons why we
homeschooled uh our kids early on
to avoid some of those pitfalls and you
know the
the future will tell us whether that was
a correct decision or not
but uh so far so good but i you know i
want to get to
some of the practices you know you
talked about um
welcoming differing points of view into
your
in into your world and into your feed so
that you're constantly being challenged
but as somebody who's
who's uh you know so successful and kind
of at the top of their field it would be
very easy for you to become calcified
around your thinking
to surround yourself with sycophants and
people that tell you you're great
but you know what i get from you is a
tremendous amount of
of humility and curiosity uh and and
this
this like desire this thirst for
learning for you know expanding your
perspective so
how can somebody who's watching this or
listening to this cultivate some aspect
of that
in their own lives so that they are you
know more vigorously challenging their
own ideas and
and and really kind of for lack of a
better phrase like falling in love with
being wrong or
or being challenged and and relishing
that as opposed to
resisting it thank you
i i i can't think of a higher compliment
than being called humble and curious
and that's who i want to be i don't
think i always show up that way
successfully but
it's certainly in my value system and
the the idea that you've taken any of
that from you know from my work
or or anything i've done is
uh is a little bit encouraging but i
don't want to be surrounded by sick of
fans
and so i my first instinct is to say
wait a minute go back
find some moments when i lacked humility
when i wasn't curious enough
and helped me learn from those and i
think the motivation behind that is the
same one that you've had
throughout your i i do want to turn the
tables on you at some point in this
conversation rich because your whole
your story as i know it is you you are a
dedicated rethinker uh you know i
everything i know about your story from
you know rethinking your
addictions to your exercise habits to
your nutrition
to now what you do for a living right
going from practicing law to
you know now you're a thought leader
you're a podcaster
you're a writer every one of those
decisions was a
major opportunity to think again and
i i want to understand better how you
did that uh i saw the look on your face
you're not going to let me turn the
tables yet so i will try to answer yours
i know you do this in lots of podcasts
and and with with varying degrees of
willingness on behalf of the host i i'll
indulge you a little bit but this is
this is about you
but i will say this um i do
find myself resistant or
somewhat calcified around certain ideas
that i have that are part and parcel of
of my identity like i'm constantly
trying not to overly identify with the
vegan thing like that's part of who i am
but i've actually worked very hard to
make sure that that's not
like the entirety of of
you know how people know me and i've
tried to you know expand my
curiosity in other directions but i feel
it coming up
particularly in the context of of
addiction recovery like as somebody who
got so you know i went to a treatment
center and then i've been in
aaa for you know over two decades at
this point
it's helped me get sober it helped me
get sober it saved my life
continued to save my life i'm devoted to
helping other people
achieve and maintain sobriety being of
service in that program
is you know core to who i am
and i've seen people's lives change in
such dramatic fashion
and i'm i'm an adherent and a proponent
of this lifestyle and yet every single
year
without fail there'll be somebody who
comes along
who says everything you know about
addiction and recovery is wrong
a doesn't work here's the new way and
i'll feel my
you know my back goes up and i get
defensive about it
um and so i'm always endeavoring to
look at that and figure out how not to
be defensive to
to um entertain new ways of thought
that in a in a manner that isn't
threatening my identity a perfect
example would be
all the work that's being done right now
in psychedelics and
and kind of the the the advent of things
like ayahuasca which
to me is anathema to my own program it's
not for me
and yet i have to acknowledge that there
is a lot of amazing science coming out
right now about the impact of these
substances
um and and i want to approach that from
a perspective of curiosity rather than
defensiveness but that's that would be
one example of where i feel it
kind of percolating up i love that
that's
that's exactly i'm
trying not to have a goal of changing
anybody's mind or behavior
but if i did have that goal it would be
for people to think exactly
as you just outlined to say even with my
core identities
that i may learn things next year that
make me want to tinker with those a
little bit
or that lead me to say yeah you know
what that's not my taste or it's not
aligned with the way that i've chosen to
live
but i can be much more open to and
accepting of other people's choices
that might be different right i think
that would be such a great starting
point for
for many people and i guess to
to answer your question i i think
i i guess where i would love people to
start if they're committed to
the idea of being open-minded is
to begin to know what they don't know uh
you you saw in the book i just just i
started making a list of
things that i'm ignorant about and my
goal is for that list to grow every day
and not to grow because i'm ignoring
those areas of ignorance
but to grow because i'm constantly
becoming aware of how many things i'm
clueless about
and i want that to do two things i
wanted one to keep me humble
so that i don't end up spouting opinions
on things that i'm completely
unqualified to weigh in on
and two for it to stoke that curiosity
to say
well why is it that i've never learned
anything about music
uh it's not that i don't find it
interesting why have i as somebody who
loves to learn
why haven't i pursued that and is that
something i want to explore at some
point in my life when
my i sort of i guess when i flip the
serial processing switch
in that direction uh so i think
everybody could keep a list like that
and the goal is as you learn new things
you also become more aware of what you
don't know it's very socratic in that
sense
the other thing that that i've found
helpful is just
detaching some of my opinions from my
identity and
trying to anchor my identity much more
in my values instead right
so you know i would have if you had
asked me what my identity was when i was
in high school or college i would have
said
i am a diver that was that was who i was
it was my screen name on america online
it was the first thing that anybody knew
about me i remember
my my uncle ira the michigan fan uncle
uh meeting one of my friends uh and
and asking what do you think adam's
gonna you know major in in college and
my friend said
diving
and it was so hard for me to walk away
from diving even though it was time when
you know both i think i had peaked
athletically
and also i started to develop other
interests but it was
extremely difficult to let it go because
it was so core to who i thought it was
and the rethinking of that i didn't have
the vocabulary for it at the time but
the rethinking of that for me was to say
what is it about diving that i'm so
passionate about
it's the quest for mastery so i really
want to pursue excellence that's one of
my values
it's the fact that i get to spend at
least 90 of every diving practice
helping other people with their dives
whether it's you know encouraging them
to try a new dive that they're afraid
of or giving them a coaching tip because
i'm standing at a different angle
while i'm waiting in line to get on the
board and that's generosity and that's a
core value of mine
it's it's integrity too it's
following through on my commitments and
saying look i'm going to learn these new
dives i'm going to show up at practice
on these days
and you can always count on me to do
that and once i started to realize that
there were values that were attached to
that activity
i said okay well i can bring those
values to anything that i do
and my hope is that that people are a
little more flexible in their beliefs
and their opinions and they really think
okay my identity is what's important to
me
not the things that i think i need to do
today
that's super interesting um
you know when i'm listening to you to
share that i'm thinking about
this uh
um gap that i think a lot of people have
between
their values or perhaps their perceived
values and their ability to execute on
them i mean you're somebody who
like when you say you're going to do
something like you freaking do it
you you have no problem uh executing
on
that isn't that the story of your
transformed life
well you're see you're trying to turn it
on me again i don't know definitely
but no but i look at you and i think
self-discipline has to be
your master virtue yeah i mean i think i
think
self-discipline and a willingness to
like i'm not afraid of suffering or
doing hard things and i'm not afraid of
being uncomfortable like
i i welcome that and i i recognize that
that's
a skill that i have that maybe my pain
tolerance is
a little bit higher than most people and
i learned that in swimming
and that served me well but also been a
pitfall in my life
and i look at you and that was one of
the reasons why i asked about diving at
the outset like
you have this ability to execute on your
goals like you
got a master's and a phd in three years
at university of michigan
there's this story that you always email
people back right away i've experienced
that like i don't know how you
like there are certain aspects like
character specific aspects of who you
are
that you seem to have developed mastery
over and whether you learn those as a
diver
or as a diligent student i don't know
but how can you speak to the person
who suffers from an inability to
marry their value systems with their
output or their actions
does that make sense it does it it's
honestly something i've had a hard time
making sense of because it's it's just
so foreign to me
well i i haven't just i have this wired
into you right yeah i mean i
i don't i don't even think i don't think
i learned
any of the tendencies you described
right i think they're just built in like
i remember
like if if you you know if if you had a
time machine and you went to meet
five-year-old me like i had a goal of
waking up as early as possible in the
morning so that i could play with he-man
characters
right and i had a whole story that i
wanted to play out and then
nothing was interfering with that the
nintendo thing too
right same yeah nintendo is just
laser-focused obsession and my problem
has always been
how do i lower those attentional filters
so that they're not blinders
and it's it's you know it's almost like
i when i meet somebody who has the
opposite challenge which i realize is
more common than mine
like i i'm i'm really i have no idea
because i
i don't do this deliberately it's just
how i'm wired
i think i mean the the best thing that
i've learned from trying to study it
is um is really what i ended up
exploring on procrastination last year
uh so i i give a whole ted talk that's
about the surprising virtues of moderate
procrastination for creativity i write
about that in a book
and then i find that most people
are not procrastinators like me they're
really struggling
with procrastination that's hurting
their productivity
that's undermining their romantic
relationships that's
causing them to be unhealthy and
i went and said okay i've got to
understand what do we know about the
psychology of preventing procrastination
and
the light bulb moment from me was some
work by uh fuchsia sora
and tim pitchell two psychologists who
have found that
that when we procrastinate it's not
because of being
it's not because of laziness and i think
you could probably say this is more
broadly true right it's not
procrastination
um many of the gaps between people's
goals and values and their daily actions
they're not because they don't want to
work hard or
they lack you know some magical amount
of grit
that's a prerequisite for for following
through
it's often because of emotions
not time and what they're not what
they're avoiding is not hard work
they're avoiding a negative emotion that
a particular task
stirs up so what i would encourage
people to do is to think about whatever
goal that you're not pursuing
or that your you know whatever habit
you're trying to build that you're
falling short on
and ask yourself what negative emotion
is associated
with the behavior that you want to do
more of or the behavior that you want to
stop doing
and you know in some cases it's fear for
people right they'll say you know i'm
i'm afraid of finding out that i can't
do it and so i would rather i would
rather just
you know put in partial effort and
sandbag it and
by self handicapping i i don't have to
ever find out if i'm capable or not
and that way i can believe that i really
have the potential one day
for other people it's uh you know it's
it's frustration
it's i tried a bunch of times i didn't
get the result i wanted
and i'm tired of banging my head against
a brick wall and so it's just
it's it's not worth the effort anymore
um for me it's boredom
it turns out i procrastinate sometimes
rich and when i procrastinate it's
shame on you i know i feel i feel like
such a fraud
i'm a hypocrite but everyone
procrastinates sometimes right
it's it's a normal human behavior and
when i do it it's because
what fires me up is intrinsic motivation
uh the intrinsic motivation to work on
an interesting problem
uh to help somebody and if i have to do
something that i think
is not exciting and that doesn't
directly benefit people
i have zero interest in doing it and so
systematically i put off tasks
that you know that fall in that the
wrong cell of that two by two of
interesting and important and
what what understanding that has helped
me do is to say okay
i will put off reading a legal contract
forever
and it sounds like you do too based on
what your life career was like
it just bores the hell out of me and
that means when i understand that i can
manage it better
because i can try to make that task a
little more interesting by
calling up a friend who knows something
about the law and saying hey would you
be willing to chat through a few of my
questions as i read this
and i know i'm going to be forced to
read it in order to have the
conversation and not waste their time
you have to remember the co-conspirator
into this yeah of course
i need an accountability buddy exactly
somebody somebody to force me to get on
task
somebody to do what i would normally do
if this were a different task
and then the other thing i'll do is i'll
just try to build in a reward afterward
and say look if i finish reading this
contract
then you know i get to watch my favorite
show which for years i had people who
would actually delete those shows
uh if i didn't live up to my promises uh
first it was college roommates
uh and then you know it was i think i
remember asking my wife allison at some
point you know can you just delete this
from the dvr because i didn't earn it
today
right and that kind of self-reward has
been you know pretty motivating from
time to time so
i it's a long answer but it's it's the
framework that i've found most useful
for for navigating this dilemma in my
own life right how do you solve it
look at you coming back with the
questions uh yeah i want to learn from
you come on this is
i honestly i really want to let me let
me just explain
um what was behind part of my ulterior
motivation
i went on this strive challenge in the
fall of 2019
that i i didn't really know what i was
getting into i got an
email invitation saying hey can you
speak at this event
it's raising money for charity great and
oh by the way richard branson is hosting
it
all right sure i'll be there and i
i kept getting these emails saying are
you training
no i'm not training richard branson is
doing it whatever he can do he's twice
my age
and you know i i did claim i was an ncaa
athlete i'm sure i'm gonna be fine you
know i work out five days a week
no problem i showed up there and that
thing
just kicked my ass
it was um it was it was in well it was
uh it's called the strive challenge and
it was
it was hiking like up and down mountains
and then swimming across a lake and then
biking
i think the longest i'd ever biked
before was five or 10 miles
and we did a 70k bike ride up a mountain
right
i was the only one with gym shoes i
didn't even think to get
clips because yeah whatever i i'm sure i
can handle it and
it was it was one of the hardest things
i've ever done because i i came so
unprepared
and i realized almost all my training
has it's been
it's been much more sprint than
endurance uh over the past 20 years
ever since i became a diver i went into
explosive power and i stopped doing
distance and endurance
and i came out of that thinking that
that was
hard it was harder than it should have
been i want to get better at this and
you're obviously you are the creme de la
creme when it comes to
doing the craziest long-term distance
and endurance challenges ever
and i want to know i want to understand
how do you motivate yourself to do those
well it
it's similar to how you responded to the
question
about procrastination like i i i'm just
wired this
i look forward to it like it's my joy
like i would prefer
to be out on my bike all day than you
know pretty much anything else so
it's not a chore and it's not something
i mean certainly there are days that i
don't want to do it
and you have to rebut you know some
resistance but
i would say by and large like it's it's
it
it's something i look forward to every
day and and always have like i got up
you know in in in high school i was
getting up at 4 45
in the morning to go to some practice
like it was very goal oriented that
then in a way that it isn't really now
now it's more lifestyle but
it brings it i feel better i'm a better
person when i'm doing it
and i enjoy the process of doing it so
the confusion lies in
in people thinking that that this is
this is something that i hate
and i do it anyway which is not the case
i i buy that and i get it i think the
mystery for me though
is there are moments when you're clearly
not in that zone and you persevere
anyway
so i'll give you a concrete example
which is
so we've done i think it was like we did
an 11 hour hike
and then we did i don't know it was
about a maybe a mile
no it's a kilometer swim across the cold
lake and then we're doing this intense
mountain bike ride that i just
i don't know how i'm going to do this
and i'm guessing
from from what the changes i made
nutritionally over the next few days for
the next bike ride
i'm guessing my electrolytes were were
just way off
or way low but there was a moment when i
was riding on the mountain
and i thought okay if i had a choice
between pedaling one more time
and dying i'm not sure that i would be
able to pedal another
and i've never felt that in my life i've
always been the person
who persists no matter what and
coming face to face with that wall and
saying i literally don't think i can do
it physically
you've pushed through that wall how sure
well first of all let's
let's finish this thread so you did
persist
right so you did take another pedal
stroke and you didn't die
yeah but i had to pause for a minute and
i was like no i don't want to pause i
don't want to
have to rest but you finished the
challenge yeah and so
walk me through the the emotional
experience in the wake of having
completed something
that was harder than you thought it was
going to be
it was one of the most exhilarating
rushes of my life
right i think i mean when people talk
about runner's high this was on a whole
another level
right that 70k bike ride we got to the
top of the mountain and
i've never taken a drug i can only
imagine that's what being high feels
like
and are you able to hold on to that
feeling
oh no definitely not not a chance but
i only get it when working out but you
can recall it
uh i remember it in a way and also
yeah i can remember what that feeling
was like i want it again
i also i feel close to that group of
people that
went through that week with me in a way
that normally would take me years
to build trust and and bond because we
all suffered together
right there's definitely uh an intimacy
that occurs when
you do something hard with other people
together that unites you in a way that
few other things do and the sense of
self
not just at having accomplished
something that was very difficult
but having pushed through that perceived
boundary
uh really expands your horizon
of what's personally possible and i find
that to be
incredibly intoxicating it is like a
drug
but it's also a fuel and it's it's
something that i need to
continually tap into to not only remind
myself
but also to persist in this desire
to push that envelope of what's possible
and there's something about that that
that
[Music]
satiates me and makes me whole in a way
that nothing else in my life does
well you you just did that was just a
master class in a motivational interview
because you asked me do i want more of
that
like i don't feel like you're trying to
convince me right i'm not convincing you
and
i just and i just shared my experience
you wanted to understand it and i'm not
i'm not attached to whether you end up
signing up for some event or not
no but i i as i hear myself talk out
loud i want to be that person i want to
do more of that
i think the other the only thing that
honestly is holding me back is the time
commitment
and that's that's the piece that also i
just
i i've really gravitated toward the
kinds of workouts and this is reflected
in my eating habits too
that save me time and allow me to feel
like i'm you know i'm making good health
choices
but you know i don't the idea that i
would commit three or four hours to
exercise
when you know i could work out for an
hour like i don't know where i'm going
to find those hours between family and
work and so
if you can help me think through that at
some other point that's the one barrier
that i haven't figured out how to crack
yet
right i think i've got a good challenge
in mind for you we could
we could take it offline but i want to
what's the challenge i'm very curious
so have you heard of the 29029
series no so do you know jesse itzler
well you know sarah blakely right
so yeah sarah was on that challenge
right actually so
jesse uh started this business called
and and it's oh i just got his calendar
is that what it is yeah i did too i got
mine in the mail
no it's different from that um it's
related but
it's a weekend experience where
a group of people descend upon a
mountain
they have a couple of them it coveted
through the whole thing off but the idea
is that
you hike up this mountain and then you
take the chairlift down it's like a ski
a ski mountain in the summertime or in
you know
warmer months and then you continue to
do that
and until you have hiked the equivalent
of mount everest which is 29
029 feet so it's a very difficult
endurance
challenge but it's also very accessible
because you do it at your own pace
it's not a race you're just hiking
you're not running you get a little
break when you take the
chairlift down but it takes like
a long time to do this and it's more
difficult than i think people realize
but
it's very doable on not a tremendous
amount of of training
and so i'm going to be doing the one in
utah
and let's see if we can't get you a slot
for that what do you think about that
sounds like fun
you're also this is this is immediately
appealing because
it it only requires intensity not
consistency
right you're not saying i have to go and
become an endurance athlete this is just
commit for a weekend
right and what's cool uh about this is
that you get
some hardcore athletes who are out there
gunning but a lot of people for a lot of
people that do this
challenge it's the first hard thing that
they've ever done and
wow the level of like sort of
self-satisfaction like it's
really amazing to see these people
in the wake of achieving something that
they didn't think that they could
or pushing through that you know
boundary
that they never have before and it's
it's really
intoxicating to see that in other people
and that
that like group cohesion and sense of
unity
and community is really quite something
that that makes so much sense that's i
think that's the thing that i miss most
about diving
aside from the just the the clarity of
knowing
exactly what i needed to work on and how
much progress i could make if i put the
effort in
as opposed to this world of ambiguity i
live in where i do a study or i write a
book or
i give a ted talk and who knows if
people are going to like it and even if
they like it if it's going to make any
difference
i miss that but i think even more than
that i miss
being part of a team that has a common
goal and i miss
especially with you know with my
teammates and the divers that i got to
coach
those breakthroughs where all of a
sudden they achieved something that they
thought was impossible for them
and it sounds like you've got a whole
experience orchestrated around that
yeah it's it's it's pretty special so
i'll i'll share some of that information
with you after can't wait
so um you spoke at the nantucket project
several years ago right like you were
like everyone loved it you were like the
top guy
um i'm part of that community i've
spoken at that event um
a couple times i think uh you you were
there the year before my first year
attending
i've known tom scott my whole life we
went to junior high school in high
school together
oh wow i didn't realize that yeah yeah
we grew up together and
in reading your book and thinking about
your work i couldn't help but think
about
um simon greer who's part of the
nantucket project community are you
familiar with him and the work that he's
doing
in a space similar to your own i don't
think i am actually
sounds like i should be yeah he's a guy
who who
um has been really devoted to trying to
have difficult conversations with people
who see the world very differently
than he does and he does these
live in front of people at the nantucket
project and he's also
done them in his clinical work where
he'll get
you know palestinians and orthodox jews
together to have a dinner party and try
to bridge the gap
and i've seen him do this with varying
degrees of success like he hosted
a conversation at the nantucket project
with candace owens that i i didn't think
went very well and then i've seen him
have a conversation with glenn beck that
i thought went
you know quite well so i was just
curious if you had known his work
because it seemed to dovetail
with so many other things that you think
about and
no clearly i need to yeah and i will be
looking it up
as soon as uh as soon as we wrap our
conversation together right right after
i
suggest a couple people that i think you
need to meet immediately
okay but the one of the things that
that i think is really interesting about
what just happened is
it just suppressed my inner politician
because when you said have you heard of
this person
i think it's my job to know everyone
who's working in the space broadly
defined that i'm working in right now
and so my temptation was okay well can i
look him up really quickly
and then you know kind of dodge the
question and not have to
admit that i don't know i don't want to
be that person
no i haven't heard of his name you just
wrote a whole book about how it's okay
to say i don't know
i know and here here i i i practiced it
but
i still felt that urge to say like i i
don't wanna i don't wanna be that guy
i also didn't wanna disappoint you
because you seemed excited to you know
to dig into the relationship between
work yeah that that whole thing went
nowhere but that's okay
no but tell me no no so here's what i
want to ask you
now knowing what kind of work he does
what's the skill that you've picked up
from observing him
for getting people whose views are so
different to at least be open to hearing
each other
well i think it's a two-way short i mean
on the one hand it
it fits perfectly with what you're
saying which is
lead with curiosity you know ask
questions be
interested uh you know refrain from
judgment you know be present like all of
these things i think are crucial
if you want to truly you know bridge a
gap
and and reach a place of of better
understanding
i think where it gets tricky and i think
this is something that came up for me in
reading your book as well
is the extent to which there's an
there's an agenda attached to that it's
like i'm going to go into
this conversation and i'm going to be
curious and i want to understand
but really what i want to do is is still
you know get you to get you to admit
that you're wrong and i'm right
yes right so talk to me a little bit
about that because
that seems to be the thing that no one
really wants to acknowledge
and i think that infects the whole uh
you know environment it does
it does the i think right away about
this work in
consumer psychology by freestat and
wright where they talk about
they call it the persuasion knowledge
model and the idea is that once you
recognize that somebody has persuasive
intent
a change of meaning occurs and now what
seemed like a genuine conversation
before
becomes a tactic and what seemed like a
chance to
explore an open discussion seems like a
situation where you have to put your
guard up
and i think that happens all the time i
i mean i i find myself both
being on the receiving end of it and as
a cause of it
much more often than i would like and i
think
the the practice of motivational
interviewing has started
it's definitely shifted my thinking it
started to shift my behavior
i catch myself doing it more often now
in real time and sometimes i don't catch
it and then a friend of mine says hey
you're lowering again here oh right oops
yep there we go again and when that
happens what i have to to step back and
ask myself is
okay are there common values here at all
are there any principles that we share
and if i can't name any i have to get
curious and find them
and then the second question i want to
ask is whatever values
we agree upon is there anything i can
learn about or
inquire about that will help the other
person
better clarify those values or how to
live those values
and where i run into trouble sometimes
is either i'm convinced that they have
the wrong values to begin with
you know like when i talk to somebody
who says well you know i know it's
selfish not to wear a mask but you know
we're an individualistic country i'm
like i can't in good faith support
living in a country where
you're allowed to harm other people uh
in fact that that violates our value of
freedom yeah
right you can't threaten someone else's
freedom then you're not in a free
country anymore
uh so i have a hard time with that and i
also have a hard time with
when i am just dead set on the fact that
the way that they're
trying to live their values is not going
to work out well for them or for the
people that they care about
and those are the moments where i get
stuck going back into prosecutor mode
but i think the rest of the time where
where i think i've had some
luck and some i guess made some progress
has been when i've said you know what
rich let me just start the conversation
by recognizing that i have a bad habit
of trying to change your mind
and i'm trying to get out of that habit
and so what i really want to do here is
interview you i want to learn from you i
want to understand your viewpoint better
and
i do have a vested interest in people
having open minds
because i believe that that's
foundational for learning and so you
might catch my questions being a little
bit tilted in the direction of
you know are there are there
circumstances that would shift your
opinion a little bit
and that's not because i'm trying to
drive you in a particular direction
it's because i'm invested in a personal
project of building a more mentally
flexible world right now
and if you object to that project i want
to hear that too because
i need to be flexible and when i've
started with that
kind of disclaimer up front it's i think
both sent the right message to the other
person but it's also
reinforced like that's me activating
cognitive dissonance if i screw up
and then i'm more likely to hold myself
accountable it is interesting
how reluctant we are to want to be wrong
like it shouldn't be such a big deal to
say i don't know
or like wow i was wrong about that like
to be able to pivot
i mean certainly you know in the public
sphere or if you're a politician
it's seen as anathema for you to change
your mind
you know it it does feel like in order
to cultivate a healthy culture
we need to incentivize
open open-mindedness you know on a
broader scale
and destigmatize this idea
of of not knowing and of saying i'm
wrong it's okay
right like our ego attachment to that is
so powerful
yeah i think it is and i i don't know
how to do that societally
i you know i i've tried to figure out
what can we do
you know in schools and workplaces even
in families right and
in cultures or systems that we have a
little bit more direct influence over
and
i think the news there is actually
pretty good right that when when
students are taught
that admitting what they don't know is
actually part of the learning process
they become more curious and
intellectually humble and they actually
learn more and do better
on tests and so creating that kind of
psychological safety in your classroom
for anyone to say hey i didn't
understand that and that's not a sign
that i lack intelligence
it's a sign that i want to pick up
knowledge right that that seems to be a
healthy
attitude for for a classroom environment
workplace it's the same thing
right let's let's stop making expertise
the currency
of success let's let's say
what we want to do is recognize that
that knowledge
is not a weapon to wield it's a resource
to share
and that means if you lack knowledge you
should not only be given permission you
should be encouraged
to go to people who might have a
perspective that you lack
and let them know what your ignorance is
so that you can try to fill some of the
gaps in your knowledge
and i think that starts with with
leaders not punishing people
for asking questions or for being wrong
it starts with in many cases just doing
something really basic which is
don't don't just reward results uh don't
just reward success and punish failure
put people in a situation where you
reward a thoughtful curious
decision-making process
and that means we could even celebrate a
good decision process with a bad outcome
because maybe that was a smart
experiment to run and we learned
something from it
and maybe we should stop rewarding good
outcomes with bad processes
because that's just luck and you don't
want to repeat that you want to rethink
your process
but the idea being that this is
trainable we are
malleable in this regard we're not born
as somebody who loves to be proved wrong
like we can create incentives around
this in our organizations and
in our interpersonal lives to cultivate
a little bit
more of this and to the extent that we
could do that
we become we're stress testing our own
ideas
we become better more creative thinkers
we become better conversationalists we
become better
uh challenged network members for our
friends and our peers and
and ultimately just better humans and
citizens
is that is that fair it's more than fair
that's okay
it's a hell of an elevator pitch for
what i hope people take away from this
set of ideas
and yeah i i don't think any of that
resistance is hardwired right there's
there's no reason why you couldn't
create
a culture or a community where people
are punished
if they don't admit they're wrong and
i think we just we've gotten that
backward in a lot of parts of the world
and you know i don't know about you but
i would rather
reward people who are interested in
developing competence
than hold up people who are full of
overconfidence
as exemplars to follow yeah you and me
both my friend
well i think that's a great uh place to
to end it but before we land the plane i
think it would be helpful or instructive
for
the listener or the viewer to have
i think the idea that i want to leave
people with is if you feel yourself
resistant to a different idea or there's
a certain personality out there that
really
you know gets your blood boiling like
how can what what's the first
step for that person to take in terms of
trying to soften a little bit so that
perhaps they could have a more
productive interaction
i think what i would recommend is to
treat that emotional response as a rough
draft
it's it's it's the first draft of how
you're going to feel
and i've never done anything where my
first draft was any good
and where i didn't want to constantly
revise and improve it
whether it was the first time i tried to
dive or the first draft of a book that i
had to throw out
or the the ted talk that i rewrote from
scratch
over and over and over again and
everybody who achieves excellence in any
domain knows that
it's the constant rewriting and
rethinking and revising that makes you
good and helps you get better and
i think once you recognize hey you know
what feeling threatened or
hating somebody else or being offended
by somebody else
that's a first draft of a response then
you can go and write a revision
and ask yourself okay is that a
teachable moment did i just learn
something
about what activates my prosecutor
instincts
or what puts me in a preaching mindset
and if i understand that better
then i have more control over what
mindset i landed
beautifully put i think you practiced
that
in the conclusion of your book where you
basically
in this very really funny and like meta
way like you basically
your conclusion is a red line that shows
like the changes and
the thoughts that went into various
drafts of of how you wanted to conclude
this book
which is not about conclusions but about
remaining open to
new ideas and possibilities i'm so glad
you got a kick out of that because it
was one of the things that was most
resistant to rethinking when i wrote the
book
i had argument after argument with this
challenge network of
brilliant former students who read early
drafts and
i said non-fiction book does not need a
conclusion
like it's not a book report and anything
else i had to say i would have already
said it
uh and they just they were so thoughtful
in convincing me that
yeah you know what i i get that you're
writing a book about rethinking
you don't want the rethinking to end but
the last page of this book
is the beginning of conversations we're
all going to have and it's the start of
a reflection process and don't you want
to give us a springboard to that
all right fine maybe you're onto
something here very very begrudgingly
and then i said well yeah you know how i
could do that a blank page
i'm just you're going to turn to the
epilogue and there's going to be nothing
there
and it's going to be the the canvas for
you to do your rethinking on
and they said yeah that's a cop-out we
can't let you do it why don't you show
us your own rethinking it's like
all right i get that this would be very
meta
and i could have some fun with it but i
really just want to be done i like
closure
not living the principles i wrote about
in the book right i need to rethink this
right well i thought it was great i've
never seen anything like that in a book
and it's
it's the perfect book to end in that
manner in this kind of circular way that
leaves it open-ended and yet still
creates some finality for the reader so
well done um i love the book i
so appreciate the the thoughtfulness uh
that you put into your work the care
you are a true giver and uh it's been
great to spend some time with you so
thank you well that is overly generous i
want to thank you for
uh for really getting me to reflect on a
bunch of assumptions that i haven't
questioned enough
and i'm also just in addition to this
being
an exhilarating conversation with a
different kind of intensity
than an endurance sport i'm also just
thrilled that i got to make a new friend
yeah cool you and me both uh i look
forward to meeting you in person at some
time
at some point and uh let's try to figure
out that endurance challenge thing
all right thank you and i want to hear
what your next challenges are and figure
out if i can be helpful with them
all right that would be great thanks
thanks if you want to connect with adam
at adamgrant on twitter pick up the book
at your favorite bookseller or go to
adamgrant.net
right is that the places that you want
to direct people you got it
all right man let's do this again i look
forward to it all right cool thanks adam
appreciate you thank you
peace
[Music]
you